the Joe Rogan experience well he did
have a conversation with Eddie Murphy
when Eddie Murphy got in trouble with
Richard Pryor with Bill Cosby rather
it's a famous story because Bill Cosby
is telling Eddie Murphy he was too dirty
he was telling him to clean it up while
he was raping people oh my god Jesus
Christ
why not drugging women and then give an
hour comedy advice Oh tell him you're
too dirty yeah telling dr. Doolittle the
watches now well he became dr. Doolittle
but back then he was Eddie Murphy raw
yeah this is actually before raw and he
put it in raw he sewed a bell causation
yeah it was um one of the one of the
opening one of the bits in bra was
Richard Pryor calling him up do the
people laugh do you get paid well tell
bill to have a coconut smile and shut
the [ __ ] up
Wow that's he said like he's do he did a
Bill Cosby impression and by the way
people forget how good Eddie Murphy's
impressions are they're [ __ ] insanely
good and his Cosby was amazing so he's
doing this Cosby impression that he does
a Pryor impression man is he still
coming back is that supposedly you know
but you'd only cross our fingers be
great for everybody
yeah great forever but I hope he blows
the [ __ ] up I hope he fills Madison
Square Garden murders and they do a
giant Netflix special there and it's
just ten times better than raw he can do
it guys still healthy still smart as a
whip you know still looks [ __ ] great
we went over it on the podcast of the
day guys is 58 years old looks like he's
35 he looks amazing so healthy you you
think he would still like push it to the
limit or do you think he would just have
like smart bits about common things like
life or whatever he would push it to the
limit of who he is today you know he's
not this 20 year old kid anymore like he
was in delirious you know delirious he
was really young I want to say he was
like 22 or something
how old was even in when he filmed Eddie
Murphy delirious we were in high school
okay so I was
probably 17 or 18 I might have just
graduated high school I think was 85 or
86 he was 22
dude you crazy oh my gosh 23 years old
22 years old and by this is first you
know you know the one right afterwards
I mean raw wasn't that long afterwards
yeah 20 so his perspectives were uh you
know young wild 22 year old dude in the
80s who's like super duper crazy famous
yeah you know when you say would he push
it now yeah he'd push it now but he'd
push it now is 58 year old Eddie Murphy
just calling [ __ ] on things
what's nonsense what's stupid and what
is and the impressions and I hope he has
20 minutes on Bill Cosby you know when I
was 22 it just just has a [ __ ] epic
bit you know SNL next week Oh Eddie
Murphy day yeah oh wow so he'll do a
little bit stand up there yeah 100% is
gonna do a monologue right yeah
god damn it but that's gonna be
excellent oh yeah the guy in wasn't he
the guy that David Spade made the
falling star joke about no what was the
falling star joke on me maybe welcome
back on SNL days David Spade had that
like that Hollywood minute segment and
and he made a controversial joke about
Eddie because I guess Eddie had just
left SNL or something like that and he
goes hey everybody look a falling star I
think it was Eddie Murphy Oh Eddie left
us or no way before that way before
David Spade's career way before to when
I was hanging out with Phil Hartman that
was in the 80s
here's about Eddie Murphy about that
this David Spade joke that kept any
Murphy off SNL for two decades huh so
maybe was because of his movies it was
definitely quite a bit after he had left
the show cuz he was he had left to show
like when delirious was out
said in an interview in 2011 that they
said some shitty things to him a couple
times after he left right but it was
quite a bit after he left yeah yeah it
wasn't like he just left and then David
Spade came on board I don't think that
was the timing I think David Spade was
on way later by the way look at that
little boy but you happen to be David
Spade
[Laughter]
[Applause]